في المقابل اتهنى وزير الخارجيه الروسيه
الدول الغربيه بمحاوله هزيمه بلاده
والقضاء عليها كمنافس جيوسياسي حسب تعبيره
واضاف ان الغرب حدد مهمته بالقضاء على
روسيا كمنافس جيوسياسي وهو ما تمثل في
القرارات التي اتخذت في قمه هيروشيما
والتي تهدف الى الردع المزدوج لروسيا
والصين حسب تعبيره
لقد حددوا المهمه بصوت عال وبشكل هزيمه
روسيا في ساحه المعركه ولا يتم التوقف عند
هذا الحد بل القضاء عليها كمنافس جيوسياسي
وبطبيعه الحال سيتم ردع اي بلد اخر يدعي
نوعا من الاستقلاليه في النظام العالمي
انظروا الى القرارات التي يجري اتخاذها في
قمه مجموعه السبع الكبار في هيروشيما
والتي تهدف الى الرضع المزدوج لروسيا
والصين لروسيا العديد من الحلفاء نحن لا
نشجع العداء تجاه اي كان لكننا مضطرون
للرد بح زم على الحرب المعلنه ضدنا